so when I looked at Madeleine McCann I
did exactly the same I I brought all the
information together I read all the
police files I spoke to all those key
witnesses around there sadly evidence
tells us
um that she would have been dead within
72 hours yeah
[Music]
so Mark obviously we've met you before
and we've done a piece with you before
but for new watches or new listeners
would you mind giving us a brief
introduction to who you were so my name
is Mark Williams Thomas I'm an invested
reporter and a criminologist and my
background really is in policing so I
was a detective I then left the Police
Service went into television and that's
where people get to know me from in
relation to my investigations I have a
series on Netflix called the
investigator and I'm probably best known
for exposing Jimmy Savile I mean that
was very concise but it was an
incredible amount of life experience in
there so I think what we'll do is go
back to the start and maybe um you know
you said you started off in the police
so how did you get there I began in
Guildford I worked on the beat as
everybody used to do it's changed now
but you used to have to go and put your
time on the ground
you know walk in the cobbled streets as
it were so I did that for just over a
year and then I thought you know it's
probably time for another change and
there was a job that came up actually a
new new job it's now common for Police
Service to have Community safety teams
so these are teams that work with people
in the community to try and keep them
out of the criminal justice system
really and we set up a vulnerable youth
team and I was a vulnerable youth
officer for the whole of the Guilford
Borough and the purpose was was to try
and keep children out of the criminal
justice system so once you get into the
criminal justice system it's a conveyor
belt it's really difficult to get off it
so what I looked at is a youth diversary
policy to try and keep people away from
crime in the first place so that you
didn't end up going into that role
constantly of seeing the same faces over
and over again
but what it did identify for me was the
need for safeguarding children because
the large majority of the children I was
dealing with these all under 18s were
coming from you know disrupted broken
homes environments where they were not
being safeguarded they were subject to
child abuse and it kind of opened up
that whole area and I became really
fascinated in child abuse in the abuse
of children and seeing what I could do
from a policing point of view to try and
reduce that and that's kind of where my
path then started to go down the area of
child protection I then started to get
involved in a lot of major crime and
then I moved into a major crime team
from there became a detective and and
finished up in the Police Service doing
working on actually on a pedophile unit
because what happened is I identified
that there was a major problem with
pedophilia across the whole of the
country not being prosecuted not being
investigated and it was kind of in a bit
of a too difficult area for the for a
long time offenders were being allowed
to get away with their crime because it
didn't fall into an area really it
didn't fall into an area of
interfamiliar abuse So within a family
environment and it felt slightly into
the too difficult area because CID
officers didn't really want to deal with
child abuse
so you know the gangs the organized
crime that was taking place you know the
vicar the the the
um school teacher you know the choir
master who was actually abusing children
on a large scale but no one was really
doing the investigation to stop that so
I went out and I started to arrest some
pretty high profile people and got a bit
of a name for myself within the force as
being you know kind of like going after
pedophiles and and I managed after a
long campaign to get the assistant chief
Constable of Surrey to finally agree to
set up a pedophile unit and it did and I
went and worked on that until I finally
left the force after the police was it
private detective is that what you moved
into yeah in essence really I moved
across to doing private detect work and
then into television yes yes because
first of all what I want to ask you
about is as a private investigator yeah
what would you say were the main
differences
between that and police work so I think
it's quite simple really so obviously I
was a police officer I've got access to
computer systems I've got powers that I
don't have as a private detective so I
can arrest people I can uh you know I
can use those powers to to gain evidence
from people uh you know I've got
um regulatory fat powers and
surveillance with
um some of the techniques that you use
you know bugging listening devices all
of that stuff at my disposal and I've
got some of that in my disposal now but
obviously it's slightly different you
know if I wanted to gain access to
someone's house to be able to put a
listening device in someone's house then
I can go through that process through a
court order get that order get into
someone's house as a police officer put
the bug in there disappear and nobody
knows I've been in the house you know
the intelligence services do it all the
time but obviously I haven't got that
access as a police officer so my ability
to get into someone's house and do some
of those things is obviously reduced
so powers and uh access to computers is
the biggest thing but as a private
detective I've still got access to
techniques so I just have to be cleverer
so I just have to be able to use the
abilities to be able to gain access to
people in a way that perhaps they aren't
aware of sure in a more discreet way can
you give us any example well I mean yeah
we use
um we might use decoys to be able to get
to people you know Amazon Amazon
deliveries are great in getting items
into people's houses oh can you actually
do that yeah why not
you've once got to show that there is a
you know there's a there's a serious
case that you're investigating I mean
you couldn't start doing those types of
things if you're investigating a you're
a theft or something like that but if
you're investigating you know Murder an
unsolved murder or somebody wanted for
rape or something like that or firearm
defenses then you know the the
proportionality of what you're doing
justifies the end so you know we lump
cars and buy lumpy so we put trackers on
cars you know so tracking on cars you
know we did the very first track on a
car that ITV ever did I remember I've
got a friend who um
who was a solicitor for for uh for MI5
and I was speaking to him and I said to
him listen you know I'd love to put a
tracker on the car but my my
um lawyer ITV will not let me do it and
he said well let me have a chat with him
and let me he says you can do it it's
obviously there's restrictions so you
know we do it and uh anyway
about an hour later I remember getting
an email from uh this list again yes we
can do it and uh but you've just got to
be really careful that you do it in a
certain way and within a matter of you
know I remember that evening
getting the tracker and heading off to
our Target's address for that evening in
the early hours of the morning about
three o'clock in the morning to get up
and put a tracker on there on the car
and um and it was great because the
first time we it had ever been used in
television we put a tracker on this car
and we were going back and um and then
you just wait for the phone to to Ping
right so you put a glac8 on it fixes it
to a certain location and the foam pings
and and off we go and we follow this car
so in a way that that's probably it's
probably easier to put a tracker in a
car in your current position than it was
when you're in the police because I
suppose as as to want to do it in the
police although you've got the legal
backing of it you have to go through a
huge system of application and all that
yeah yeah I mean I think the process in
terms of getting things now is is other
than the Police Service servically much
quicker yes you can you know the ability
to be able to get some of the devices is
harder because you know I can't I can't
tap someone's phone I can't get into
someone's physically get into someone's
house and and you know and put a
listening device in there but there are
sometimes other ways of doing it you
know there may well be that somebody we
can we know somebody within that house
who is prepared to put a device
somewhere or record something and you
can put a listening device inside
someone's house weak we the person would
have to do it themselves so they'd have
to be somebody who's physically within
that house who's prepared to record
something or do something but it's all
about proportionality you know it's all
about what is it we're trying to do what
is it we're trying to achieve if
somebody's on the run for for very
serious offenses then yeah there is a
justification for doing things that
makes sense and correct me if I'm wrong
but it sounds like what helps is when
you were talking about the tracker on
the car it sounds like what helped that
become a possibility was a very in-depth
knowledge of the law and which and how
you can do things and how you can't do
things do you ever feel exposed for that
because then if someone if a policeman
comes along catches you doing it and you
say no it's okay to do that as long as
it's and they don't have have that
in-depth knowledge they might say
doesn't sound right yeah I mean I we've
we um I remember we did a surveillance
on this person's address and the
producer the producer said first of all
he said I'm going to sit in the bin
right as in a wheelie bit oh wow outside
this address and he hadn't done any
surveillance before and I said believe
me you're not going to sit at the
wheelie bin for very long I said it
might be fine for a while but you can't
move it's ridiculous I said lie in the
back of the car I said we'll park the
car further away and you can lie in the
back of the car anyway he did but he
then decided that he was going to move
the car I think it was or he was moving
around too much within this car and a
neighbor saw him moving an awful lot and
phoned up the place and then the next
thing the police turned up and uh and
then he phoned up and said all the
police are here anyway we managed to to
get the place and take them away from
the Target's address talk to them
elsewhere and say look we're done
running an operation we're running this
the Police Service are you know I have
great relationships with the people
service I get on very well with them and
you know we have a good dialogue most of
the time it's really interesting so
you've moved from the police force where
you uh you you sort of ended up doing a
lot of work with children yeah and then
you moved into the kind of private
investigative world and the TV work
started to come alongside that in a
similar time where was it that the Jimmy
Savile thing came in
so I'd be doing I've done quite a lot of
Television stuff so I've probably done
quite a lot of ITV tonight programs uh
you know I went over and and confronted
a pedophile priest in Germany who sat in
a internet cafe and told me about orders
offending just the camera incredible
really
um but I think you know that broke down
yeah we'd be following him for a little
while and I went the the exec said to me
you know he needs to be I said to him we
need to be confronted he said what are
you up for that I said yeah I've got so
much just just that everything I used to
do in a police service I just went and
confronted they went for half an hour
told me that all his offending behavior
and was he prosecuted yeah he was
Prosecuting convicted for for
um he had a load of child abuse material
as well as grooming a child right so I
did that and then I did a lot of other
crime stuff so I did did
um quite a few tonights around crime
stuff and then I was working
um I think I was working on another
tonight program or or I'd be doing some
stuff actually those days I used to do
quite a lot of BBC News night as well
and then I was just going to I was just
coming back from BBC News night having
filmed a piece in Interpol I've gone
over to Interpol to to deal with uh a
child rescular child trafficking and
I've just come back and the producer
said to me have you ever heard anything
about Jimmy Savile being a sex offender
and I went no I said he's a weird bloke
I said I wouldn't want him anywhere near
kids but you know I've never heard
anything what year was this so this is
2011. he was picking up audiences of you
know 15 17 million a night you know he
was phenomenal he was he was a cross
there was only two television channels
there was ITV and and BBC in those days
you know BBC One BBC Two he was a
Crosshair on a Saturday night BBC One he
was he was it
um yeah an absolute star really in terms
of of Television worldwide known as well
you know big big profile so the thought
I guess some of the nervousness is the
fact that you're not going after someone
that's people are suspicious of already
at that point in time you're going after
someone that you you're going to be
telling them you know that person you've
enjoyed watching all of your life
because he started so early late 60s
yeah 60s all the way through and of
course he'd become stable diet for many
many families on a Saturday night
watching Jim will fix it yeah you know
top of the pops he'd become iconic in
the way that he was and people kind of
accepted him he became that you know
that face of Saturday night television
so I was taking on something which was
pretty massive uh yeah 2011 so the
producer said to me have you ever heard
anything I went no not at all I said I
it's weird and he said well he was
arrested by a police service for child
abuse offenses for sexual offenses and I
went oh I'd never heard that he said
well it was interesting enough it was
either your old force or Sussex I said
well I've not heard that but I'll make
some inquiries and and I'll see I said
what are you going to do with it he said
well we can't do a program until he's
dead no one will touch it and I said
that's a shame and I said what have you
got he said well and he became a con bit
convoluted because basically he was a
producer and his aunt was at a
children's home where Jimmy Savile used
to visit and so that's how he knew the
story really and there was quite a lot I
then looked online and I read quite a
lot of stuff naming Jimmy Savile as a
sex offender and a number of other
celebrities so I we spoke a bit a little
bit about it and I said look I'll make
some requires I then managed to find out
using contacts in mind that yes Savile
had been interviewed at Stoke Mandeville
by the police in relation to some
allegations to sexual offense and this
you could find this out on the internet
right so this was secret yeah so I'd
found it out and actually I found it out
from somebody who was your very senior
officer who told me it and I think the
moment he told me he then thought what
have I just said because he told me that
and then I tried to speak to her about
four or five days later and he wouldn't
right okay so and he realized what have
I just said I've opened up these can of
worms anyway I so I went back to the uh
producer and said look he has been
arrested sorry he has been interviewed
in relation to these allegations
um but no further actions coming from it
and he said okay that's a shame and what
are you feeling at the moment because
you've been looking online you've spoken
to this yeah I mean are you like oh do
you think something no there's clearly
more to it right it was clearly more to
it uh and I said to him what are you
gonna do with it he said well we've got
to you know we've got somebody that's
going to present it and we're just kind
of working it up and see where we go but
you know we can't do anything at the
moment and then fast forward a couple of
months not very long and he dies Savile
dies and I remember thinking to myself
gosh that's your moment he's now because
you can't you can't be sued by the Dead
so I thought there's a moment and I
remember he phoned me up he said we're
going to do it uh he said you know would
you give us an interview in relation to
that because of your background in terms
of dealing with very high profile
offenders in the police service and I
dealt with a number of high-profile
offenders in the police service and um
when you were in the police yeah when I
was in the police during the Police
Service I you know uh I worked on a
number of very high profile cases
and so I said to him yeah yeah no
problem at all and and then he went to
the editor of newsnite and the editor of
new tonight
totally missed the ball here because he
said well there is no story because
Surrey please don't seem to have failed
in their investigation they dealt with
it appropriately
and I remember saying Tim but that's not
the story the story is that Jimmy
savile's a sex offender yeah it's not
the secondary whether or not the police
failed in their investigation so I he
said well that's it we're we're shutting
it down we're not doing anything I
remember saying to him well there's
something here I don't know what it is
yet and there's something here and I
said but are you would you be happy for
me to take it on you know journalistic
realize you don't want to tread on
someone else's toes if he feels that
he's going to continue doing he said
well it's dead for me I can't do
anything with it this is a producer
saying yeah yeah it's definitely I can't
he said I'll help you all I can he said
obviously I have to be careful because
of my role but I said I'll help you all
I can so I said well let me run with it
let me see what I can find and I
remember
and all they had at that moment in time
was they had a complainant at the
Children's Home not allegations against
Savile but they get allegations against
another offender but talking about how
Savile would go to that place okay and
obviously they had the details of the
other offenses that took place that
they'd been interviewed for so I started
to think there's more to this I remember
going to itvl I remember saying to the
lawyer there is something in this there
is definitely something in this but we
need to run with it anyway the lawyer
was incredibly nervous the exec said
well Mark listen why don't you and
Leslie who's my producer why don't the
two of you work on it and see where you
go I remember we started to to work on
it and I there's a couple of things I
have decisions I made I said one is
we'll keep everything on paper off
computer so so we weren't putting
anything on YouTube I didn't want this
story to leak I didn't want this story
to be looked at by the people we had to
keep it really tight I think that the
Cecilia bosses Within ITV started to
slightly hear about what was going on
and they were definitely nervousness
massive nervousness and I remember one
occasion when somebody from the
um one of the teams turned around and
said well you need to go and get a
consent form signed before you do the
interview the day before and you have to
tell them exactly what it's all about
and then see if they're happy to do it
and I said what are you talking about I
said I'll do it in the same way as I
would do any other consent I'm not going
to give them the day before we've talked
about it all and just just to just for
people listening that aren't aware of
how all the TV stuff works and all that
so
when already it sounds like when you're
discussing this particular project it
feels as though that you're meeting
resistance maybe not huge amounts of
wrists but you're nervous about people
hearing about it you're getting
nervousness from lawyers would that is
that equivalent to other shows you've
done where you've gone and I suppose the
priests in Germany is always at
resistance around exposing a pedophile
because if you get it wrong it's so
dangerous or did you feel it because it
was Savile specifically there was an
extra layer of resistance there yeah I
think as in the initial stages it was
the same resist same nervousness I
wouldn't say resistance the same
nervousness existed within the Senior
Management because of course it's
reputation and you know ITV examples of
PLC it's not that you know it's not
funded by you and I like the BBC is and
so so there's a nervousness for
shareholders
rightfully so you don't want to get
something like that wrong no and so
there was it was about the same as doing
any risky program I do I do a lot of
risky programs and but then that
nervousness did increase and the
nervousness increased because I think
there was a reality of quite what we
were doing and then when we started to
find victims you know we found five
victims we found six victims I remember
going back to the bosses and saying we
found them and they said well keep
looking and I remember saying at one
stage how many do you want yeah you know
because one of the very clear things I
do in all my programs is that if I'm
going to interview somebody then that
that will appear in the program right
you know I I work particularly if
they're a victim if they're a
contributor it's a very different matter
you're an expert or whatever it is but
if they're a victim and they're giving
me their victim account you know one's
gonna be really careful how we treat
people so I would use that in the
program and so we'd reached a point
where the evidence was really really
really strong and I remember going back
to the bosses and they said
it is good but I think you need to do we
probably need somebody just to run it
past and see what their view is so I
said well okay let's use two people so I
use the Barrister who I knew QC and he
said look the evidence is pretty
compelling there and then I used Esther
Ransom
oh and Esther I I know Esther very well
and I phoned Esther up and I said listen
Esther
slightly strange this but I've
investigating Jimmy Savile so obviously
said look this is all in confidence I'm
investigating Jimmy Savile I've got
three videos I'd like you to watch of
complainants giving their accounts and I
don't want to I don't want to preempt it
I don't want to show you anything before
I just want to come around your house
show you these three videos film it all
and I want your response and of course
she knew Savile you know she was part of
the BBC for anyone that might not be
aware Esther Ranson is a quite famous
British TV personality oh yes I mean
Esther Ransom set up childline so
childline is the telephone number in in
the UK where children you know people
come phone up about being abused she has
done an incredible amount of work for
safeguarding children you know she's a
she's a you're a leader right up the
front leading in relation to
safeguarding of children for many many
decades now and so real Authority in
terms of that and yeah a lovely lady I
get on with it very very well and I said
to Alice I'm going to show you these and
I remember turning up by her house she
was quite Fierce you know it's very
different as a presenter of a program
you get a very different response
sometimes than if you're a producer or
researcher and she can be quite Fierce
and I remember she was quite fierced to
my producer well I'll change it to a
very famous British person quite famous
um and I remember sitting down and I
said right let's I'm just going to play
this and I played it and
you could the as she was watching this
you could you could feel kind of like
the
yeah I suppose anger coming through but
also she was in the moment and she cried
and she cried and they were genuine
tears absolutely genuine tears and she
said you know what
I believe them absolutely believe them
you know we gave them a platform and we
allowed him to abuse and it was kind of
like a moment of thought that's it
that's the moment that's the the
definitive moment that you know I live
in this world and I've investigated him
for a year
but when you get somebody outside who
looks at this who's got some knowledge
and looks at it and goes do you know
what I believe that were you
categorically certain that he was a
prolific as sexier yeah I mean me in the
months prior to that no doubt about it
you know Dad's but he got away with it
for a very long time and being able to
use his power to get away with it oh you
had no doubt about it and there was you
know as it was going on more and more
people I was finding more and more
information from people more and more
victims were coming forward yeah no
doubt about it at all and and the yeah
the eve of
so that the program went out midweek and
I remember on the Sunday uh the mail the
mail on Sunday we'd given an exclusive
to mail on Sunday and um and they
bottled it and they put it on page six
or seven uh I remember them saying to me
you know is that enough information
really we've got any more you can give
us and I remember that's it and then
this the
um Sunday Mirror and the Sunday people
who were who I'd got a very good
relationship with I gave them some other
stuff and they ran it on the front page
and it ran
consecutively for 41 days on the front
pages of the newspapers did the Jimmy
Savile story that's how big it was it
was phenomenal here and more and more
information coming out all the time yeah
41 consecutive days his story sat on the
front pages and and that's how big it
was I mean you know he got mentioned in
the house Commons you know I got
specifically mentioned by Tim Layton the
um children's Minister there you know
about the work that we've done it's
collected you know numerous amounts of
awards and But ultimately you know that
was only possible because of the
braveness of the women who came forward
you know had they not have given me
their accounts and allowed me to use it
on television
we wouldn't have succeeded because I
needed them to to be listened to I
needed them to be believed yeah I
crafted it yes and I took the the uh you
know the weight and the force of it from
them but ultimately they were the reason
it happened and some people would say
yeah but you never bought Justice well I
wasn't down to me you know I'm not I'm
not out this is this cape Crusader who
wears a cape and fighting for people's
Justice at all cost yes I go out there
and I do my best but ultimately that's
the system you know and the system was
such that he evaded Justice before he
died well also yeah you didn't know he
was gonna die right so well he made the
Justice before he died the authorities
had the opportunity to get him if they
did on the proper investigation and they
failed they categorically failed you
know on a seismic scale when they could
have done because all the information
that I had was available had they have
done some investigations when they
interviewed him uh in the early 2000s so
I didn't do anything different I just
was thorough in my investigation whereas
they were utterly unthur in there and
what year did it go out with the
document your 2012 yeah because I
remember I was working at the BBC when
it went out and I watched it and I
remember there was a what it felt like
was there was a there was a little
Tipping Point where it went out everyone
was talking about it but for about three
or four days there was all these
accounts of there was arguments about
whether it was true or lies and they
were being broadcast they're in papers
and people were saying he'd never do
that and then it just felt like this
damn cracking and suddenly it was just
like an outpouring of more and more and
more information just spraying out
across you know just Decades of horrific
abuse coming to light and I remember the
a lot of the conversation was
I was obviously younger it was just like
a lot of the conversation me and my
peers were having is like
how the hell has this happened yeah well
it could have been stopped you know the
Police Service had plenty of
opportunities over the decades to to
stop it but they didn't and because
nobody ever did a thorough
investigational work that was a problem
well because they were incompetent you
know individual officers were
incompetent they failed to properly
investigate him I think they were
I think they were overcome by power and
an influenced you when you're a police
officer you don't tend to probably meet
many famous people and so it depends on
you as a character as to how you cope
with that
and and I think that as a result of that
that influences sometimes your decision
making you know we've seen it we saw it
with Savile we saw it with the Lost
Prophet singer uh when the police got a
bit in awe of him
um so I think that's it yeah I
I know lots of famous people you know I
I've worked with an awful lot of them I
work very close with Simon Cowell you
know we work together on projects and um
and so I've seen you know I've mixed
with all the a-lists I know them and I
think probably for me it was like do you
know what he's just like anyone else you
know but I don't think the police
officers saw that and they certainly
didn't see that when they were
investigating it well that's one side of
it is the police officers and that I
feel like that's a very logical
reasonable account of why these kind of
things might have happened but the other
side of it is the people who put him on
TV yeah because one of the things that
came out afterwards was people saying oh
I'd heard stuff I'd heard stuff I'd
heard stuff I'd heard stuff and even I
think I remember Louis Theroux did like
a kind of like um a piece after after
he's passing and said there were always
rumors about him
and that's one of the other things I
think people have been confused about is
that
if it was this weird Open Secret yeah
how was he just on prime time TV for so
long well there Dame Janet Smith came
out she did a review for the uh BBC
um and her review was pretty flawed
really because ultimately got the right
conclusion but the outcome of it was
then flawed because she said you know
there were senior managers within the
BBC particularly the Radio setup who who
had the information
but then they did nothing with it but
she doesn't criticize them in any way at
all it's ridiculous so let's be very
clear there were people out there senior
managers within the BBC who could have
stopped it who could have stopped this
because they could have stopped him from
being involved in these programs could
have stopped the process
um but they didn't do anything they
ignored that process there are other
people who had a lot of information but
were powerless you know nurses victims
of his who's going to listen to them no
one was going to listen to him he was
incredibly litigious he wrote litigious
letters all the time in other words
letters from solicitors criticism
telling people you can't say anything so
people were silenced he was very very
powerful but there were people within
management within the BBC and other
setups who could have done something and
and I hope those people you know have
restless sleep about it all it probably
back to normal now but you know they
they need to be held accountable and
this is the problem with the whole of
the Savile you know when Netflix came to
me and said you know would I be involved
in a Netflix program
um I said there's only one program I
will make and that is holding those
people to account I can tell you there
are people out there and I and I did a
several update which started to look at
some of those people who should be held
to account
um but there is a program still to be
made to hold Savile to account and there
are people out there who will fall under
that you know there are at least five or
six people that uh that I could
investigate a name who new information
and failed to do anything because they
were scared or they didn't care or
what's your opinion on it I think it's
very difficult to judge that whether
they were scared I think they were
probably scared of of putting their head
above the parapet I think they were
scared of their position I think they
were probably uncertain about quite what
to do
and they were in awe of his power I mean
one of the massive problem is is that
Savile was earning money for the BBC and
for other organizations you know Savile
was this face so if you suddenly say do
you know what we're going to get rid of
that and of course what's the Fallout
from that it's huge because people start
asking questions so for some people it's
much easier to do nothing
even though that's the wrong thing to do
then to do the right thing now I've
never been like that you know if I make
myself unpopular which I have done and
do do by doing things if I've done it
for the right reasons then I can sleep
at night and I can hold my head up high
well when you talk about making yourself
unpopular am I right in thinking there
was actually some sort of device yeah
I've had I have death threats you know
I've been threatened to be shot I've had
child abuse material sent to me I've had
an incendiary device sent to me uh you
know I'm very careful you know I'm just
about to start on a on a new project
where I've been told that the people
that we are going after will come after
us
why would you do that
because because I care because I care to
help you know I kind of and I don't say
this in the spirit spiritualistic way is
I've been put on this Earth
I think to help people
and I'm here making a difference in
whatever way I can you know and mine is
through journalism through
investigations you know I've been
incredibly successful and I continue to
be and I'm passionate about what I do
and I don't think anybody
should be silenced
if they have the right thing to say or
if they've been let down and you know
I've I'm here now you know 52 years old
and I've survived threats
and and I'll be here for a lot longer
you know it's those people that I don't
know about I probably should be more
worried about you know um I've you know
I've dealt with some pretty nasty people
across my life and I'm still here so you
know bring it on if you're going to do
that then well let's see you what you've
been doing and in a funny way your
career sort of set you up for the Savile
thing because it was policing then
policing oh yeah I couldn't have done it
without that we have the background
children and then you've got the private
investigation and that all kind of leads
up to this but looking at it from the
outside and when you're talking about
these kind of uh you know going off into
Cambodia and all that kind of thing you
know some people might go I'm gonna
donate 100 pounds to charity a month
yeah what you're doing is ultimately
putting yourself into potentially danger
well potentially mortal danger when
you're off in these foreign lands with
people that you say are very dangerous
people
what is it is it a sense of Injustice
and annoys you about it or what is it
that makes you have that passion to put
yourself into such a dangerous situation
rather than go I'm going to go after
another German priest yeah yeah I mean I
think there's a number of things isn't
it I mean I think I I couldn't I can't
deny the fact that there's an adrenaline
element to it also you know being a
police officer you know being in that
position where you're frontlining you're
changing things and you're responding to
things corsets and adrenaline and Buzz
to that but that adrenaline buzz you
know is it is a process out of why am I
doing it in the first place you know why
am I doing it I'm doing it because I
want to help people you know I feel that
I have the skills and the ability and
the contacts to make a difference to
people's lives you know I want to shine
a light in the darkest of Corners I want
to give a voice to those people who have
been let down by the authorities I I'm I
get incredibly angry with Injustice I
get incredibly angry with incompetence
um and particularly when I see something
is wrong
um I want to fix it yeah I'm a fixer you
know it's um you know if whatever's
going wrong in someone's life when
they're close to me I want to fix it and
you know and I'll come up with all those
options how to do it you know I I that's
what I am and I think when someone comes
to me with that Injustice
I think of it and go I can help you I
can make a difference with Savile if I
think for a lot of the British public
that will have come out of nowhere
because there'll be people that work in
media and might have heard stuff
there'll be people there's always jokes
because you work with kids but there's
jokes about anyone that works kids right
but for a lot of people that would have
come out of nowhere do you think that's
a once in a generation thing or do you
think that's something that came to
light and behind the scenes there's
other things going on that could come to
light with enough investigation so I
think we have to understand what Saba
was about Savile had this platform
created in best part by him but also by
the environment that he was in and by
those people that allowed him to have
the platform that he had he was fairly I
probably would get it he was Untouchable
and as a result of that he was allowed
to do what he wants now if you put that
into today's society it's very different
there wasn't a social media there wasn't
the platform to expose him that there is
today you know you couldn't get away
with those things today because someone
would write a blog someone would do a
social media post someone would do
something about it and talk up and
Society is for is far less accepting of
wrong as it was in those days you know
do you think so oh yeah I mean you know
the the whole me too movement it's been
brilliant because actually you know and
people would say off the back of Savile
and some of the other people arrested
yeah but it was only touching it was
wrong it was wrong back in the 60s it
was wrong back in the 50s and it's wrong
today because people got away with it
doesn't make it right
societies and our perceptions have
changed we've become much more educated
around what is right and what is wrong
what is acceptable for us to have happen
to our own bodies so I think there is a
massive change and actually misogyny is
a huge thing as well you know misogyny
existed within the police service and
still does to a small degree now but to
a massive degree I mean I I did a big
investigation for a program recently on
the Yorkshire Ripper yeah this is a man
who killed 13 women in Yorkshire in the
1980s attempted to murder seven others
that he was convicted of and the
misogyny that stopped him from being
caught much earlier was horrific you
know the if you were a prostitute in the
1980s and 90s you have no value you
weren't considered to have the same
value as other people and Society still
does that to a degree now you know
everyone has a value on their head some
people are worth more than others that's
the reality it's shocking but that's the
reality it's less so now
but it certainly was a huge problem in
the 80s and 90s so Savile
to exist today I don't believe could get
away with it
there are other people who have offended
in the 80s and 90s on a large scale not
to a scale of several I don't think but
to a large scale who are still at large
there are people offending today who are
still at large on both the child abuse
point of view and also other major
criminal offenses so yes I I think there
is definitely offenders out there who
have got very serious offenses behind
them on a large scale do I think that
they're on the scale of Savile no and
because offending is about two key
aspects access on opportunity access to
your victim and the opportunity to
offend and if you look at Savile Savile
had access to his victims on a huge
daily creative television programs that
gave him access to Children he did all
this work gaming Maxes to children and
the opportunity he was given the
opportunity to be alone with children to
have that opportunity to offend so as a
as an offender you've got to have access
and opportunity to offend to whoever
your victim is going to be and Savile
had that in abundance there are
offenders out there who are still to be
brought to justice but I don't believe
there are any of them on the scale of
Savile okay
yes
um I mean
I'm not sure what my sponsors are
because I want to say well that's good
but it's definitely not good if you're
saying that there are still offenders
out there on a large scale in fact yeah
I mean majority of child offenders child
abusers will have abused in excess of
100 children
like by the time they're caught the
offenders offenders offend
um
with a with a pretty insatiable appetite
at times you know some of these people
will offend a huge huge amount before
they end up being caught you know the
first time you get caught shoplifting
will not be the first time you've
shoplifted
so if you use analogy across the board
and it's exactly the same you know the
first time you get caught unless you're
very unlucky you know won't be the first
time you've committed that offense and
offenders are the same and what we know
about child sex offenders is they are
yeah they're offending behavior is
something that it's repetitiveness and
it is a is a creature of habit
um and we know that child offenders work
on a cycle of offending so rather like a
drug you know the first time you commit
your sexual offense
you get a height as a result of that
right for an offender but it's very hard
then to get that height again but you
enter this cycle of offending which is
exactly the same as drugs your first hit
and you keep going and you go you know
and it takes something to stop you on
that cycle of offending so that you
don't continue to offend now sometimes
those barriers that are in the place to
stop you do stop you the likelihood of
getting caught I'm going to lose my
family I'm going to lose my job I might
go to jail you know my reputations can
be damaged
but there are people who use cognitive
distortion to get over those barriers
and by cognitive distortion I mean
they're able to justify in their head
that actually they won't suffer that I
won't get caught the police are rubbish
they won't catch me oh it's okay for now
sex offenders because there's so many of
them and actually you know people turn a
blind eye to that it's okay I can still
work because they'll still employ me
because I don't work with children so
this justification in your head the
whole time this cognitive distortion
that everyone uses every day set off to
work in the morning and you might use
cognitive distortion I drove 40 miles an
hour in a 30 mile an hour speed limit I
didn't drive 50. it was only 40. that's
cognitive distortion people use it all
the time to justify why they're doing
something which is wrong
um but in the same way as there are you
know thousands of child sex offenders
out there there are also thousands of
killers out there I did a huge piece of
work recently in uh England Wales and
Scotland and there are near nearly 3 000
unsolved murders oh my God since 1960s
unsold murders and that is a shocking
number do you think to self okay so if
there's three thousand unsold Motors and
that's purely classified unsolved so
there'll still be people who are missing
that have not been classified as
unsolved murders
so if there are 3 000 unsolved murders
there are offenders out there three
thousand murderers well you or a number
of serial killers my God that's even
worse
you know I often you know refer to
things you know you just imagine you go
to the shop and the person holding the
door actually could be a killer um
we walk past them all the time and the
problem is of course is offenders don't
wear something different to anybody else
you know they then walk along with a
with a you know a a bag a loot bag on
their back or they don't walk along with
tattooed across their forehead saying
I'm a pedophile they live amongst us
from one high profile case this other
one you mentioned earlier another high
profile case involving a child which is
Madeleine McCann yeah we've seen that's
a documentary you're currently working
on no so finished it it went out on
channel five a couple of months ago and
it's just about to land on uh Paramount
plus so actually next week I remember
plus well next week uh three-parter and
it was for the very first time so when I
got approached to make it I've made lots
of Madeleine McCann investigations I was
on the ground when Madeleine disappeared
within 72 hours were you I didn't know
that yeah so I flew out to Pride I lose
and I was on the ground within 72 hours
covering for Sky News and covered it you
know for about 10 days morning evening
doing you know live
talks outside and and it became part of
my life you know a huge part of my life
actually
um
it kind of took over its times because
it was such a massive story a massive I
mean worldwide you know I mean in my
time in covering television I've
probably covered the biggest crime
stories so obviously Jimmy Savile I
covered uh Madeleine McCann I got the
world exclusive interview with Oscar
Pistorius murders uh in cases where
people have admitted murder to me some
huge huge cases out there and I think
you know Madeleine McCann sits right up
the top of that in terms of profile in
terms of coverage and I finally said
okay let's make a program about it but
let's do it in a different way and and
we know over the last couple of years
there was a suspect named by the Germans
at Christian B and I said let's go and
investigate what they have on him and
and I started to investigate it and then
we went on the road for six weeks uh
Germany Portugal and we did a years-long
investigation and we got access to
Christian B
through his lawyer talked to him in
prison uh very close to getting an
interview with him prison but the prison
authorities refused us to do that and he
we basically uncovered an alibi for him
oh wow to show that actually the German
authorities are wrong and it's now
become a slight battle between the
German prosecutor and me where the
German prosecutor has been quite
critical of me and I've been critical of
him he's absolutely responsible for
murdering Madeleine McCann well no I
don't think he is for a start but
ultimately that's not your call that's
the Court's call to to make that
um
but the sad reality is is as long as we
go looking or as long as the com the
country is focused on looking for
Christian bees evidence and of which
they've been investigating him now for
nearly four years and they haven't got
enough evidence to prosecute him that
tells you at all
um the real killer is out there
this show is sponsored by betterhelp on
this podcast we meet lots of people who
are very life experiences but the
through line that we always get from
almost all of them is that talking helps
often people think therapy is about big
things offer people with huge problems
but in my experience personally therapy
has been about small things just as much
as big things if you're suffering and
you've got problems talking to licensed
therapists and counselors is a way to
get tools that will help you deal with
them in your daily life as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
matched three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
of your first month at betterhelp.com
minutes with that's betterhelp
help.com minutes with
so it's interesting you say the real
killer is out there yeah so I've
listened to a lot of podcasts on
modeling McCann like and as somebody who
doesn't have the experience that you do
and is just kind of listening to
different people but present different
types of evidence I'll listen to one and
go oh well clearly that's what happened
I listened to the second and go oh God
clearly that's what happened yeah and
then maybe the third will actually just
disprove the first two yeah
as someone who's been investigating it
since the beginning have you had a
changing opinion or have you had an
opinion that has stayed fairly solid
throughout no so the thing is with
opinions is it's important not to give
an opinion until you've got all the
evidence to support that opinion
um and of course it's really important
to listen to all the evidence so one of
the things that I do with any
investigation is I take on board all the
evidence that comes in and before I
determine the outcome of what I believe
I've heard everything I did a program
about Diana Princess Diana so it's it's
just got out
um worldwide Princess Diana The Untold
the ultimate truth and actually what I
did is I I didn't know whether Princess
Diana was murdered by the authorities by
The Establishment the the royal family
the intelligence services or was it a
tragic accident and I set off on this
path to find out and ultimately
established through evidence very
clearly you know it's a very thorough
investigation it was a tragic accident
and so when I looked to Madeleine McCann
I did exactly the same I I brought all
the information together I read all the
police files I spoke to all those key
Witnesses around there and
um you know I had a contact via not
directly but uh by one person removed
with the family
and so I was able to put all this
information together and and my
conclusion is is that on that night of
Madeleine's disappearance she woke up
looking for mum and dad and she'd been
told the following the morning that if
she were to wake up the parents were
only in the tapas bar which was just
across the courtyard because what we do
know is Sean Emily's the um uh Francisco
had woken up
on the previous nights a number of times
and and I suspect as a result of that
Madeleine thought well where is mum and
dad because they'd been out on those
previous nights as well and so I believe
she woke up she left the apartment we
know the apartment was insecure so the
back patio door was open uh and the
reason it was open it was to allow some
flow of air it was very hot and there
was no air conditioning in those
apartments and so I believe she got up
and she went wandering and looking for
her parents
and in order to come out of that
apartment you have to go onto the main
road where there's a footpath to travel
down the footpath to then go back into
the apartment to go to where the tapas
bar is and and I believe that nobody
went into the apartment Madeline left
that apartment that night everything
supports that there's no evidence that
suggests somebody has gone into that
apartment
uh and there is evidence when you look
at cases and and I did yeah I did a lot
of research around child abductions and
actually so much so that went over to
um Texas and spoke with the FBI and at a
conference around child abductions uh
looking at our cases looking the case
they have and we've got two very
prominent cases in the UK Jeanette Tate
who went missing in the 1970s she was
cycling up at the top of the hill down
the top of the hill she was a matter of
minutes away from her friends and by the
time they got to the bottom of a hill
her bike was on the floor and she'd
vanished
yeah matter of of minutes you know 90
seconds to do uh to two three minutes
and then we've got um Sarah Payne who
went uh Missing uh she vanished she was
walking off with a pet walking out with
her parents they're walking across the
field she went through this hole in the
fence and as she went through this hole
in the fence parents were just behind
and as they come through that she's
vanished unfortunately uh Sarah's
brother sees a white van just drive away
and that was the uh Roy Whiting who was
the kidnapper who took it and what that
tells you is that on both of those
occasions we don't know who abducted uh
Jeanette Tate although we think it's
black who's now dead but in relation to
Roy Whiting who did abduct Sarah pay
what we know is it was utterly
um unplanned spontaneous did not know he
was going to abduct a child but it
wasn't Sarah it was totally
opportunistic and what we know about
child abductions where there are
stranger abductions they are
opportunistic if you abduct a child you
know who that child is which is the
majority of the child abductions then of
course that's planned and you know who
the child is but when it's opportunistic
when it's not somebody known to the
um the child
that is not planned in terms of who the
victim is so I believe that she walked
out on the road and in a matter of of
seconds was abducted by a predator
outside now that supports all the
evidence we know about looking at child
abductions opportunistic Moment In Time
matter of seconds and minutes before
abducted and obviously not known to the
offender and and I believe that that's
what's happened and I sadly also
evidence tells us through the FBI
um
child abduction
manual which is very very detailed and
very good because they've got 10 times
as many child abductions as strange
child abductions that we've had in the
UK
um that she would have been dead within
72 hours yeah
yeah
awful
and do you think we'll ever know
do you think we'll ever have concrete
evidence for what happened
sadly I think it's probably unlikely but
I always use a caveat is that we have to
remain positive that one day we will you
know and I remain that with all my cases
that I remain positive that one day
ultimately that that offender will be
brought to Justice and I have to believe
that because otherwise there's no point
in doing what I do
um you know I will continue to fight for
that Justice whether it be
you know the the cases that we all know
about
um or you know other cases I've got a
case in in Coventry The Disappearance of
Nicola Payne and she vanished and she's
never been seen since and I you know I'm
working on a program and a podcast now
to get Justice because I know who killed
her
wow
wow that must be quite a lot to live
with yeah and I think it's it's I have a
lot of information I mean I have a lot
of information comes to me uh because of
the type of work I do so obviously I
know about uh lots of operations that
have been run I know about lots of
offenders out there where there isn't
quite enough evidence to prosecute
I also know a lot of people's dark
secrets you know during the course of um
I investigated Max Clifford and Max
Clifford used to
um used to effectively blackmail some of
his clients and uh and I've got some a
number of very high profile people who
he blackmailed
um and and I know their stories about
how he blackmailed them
um you know the stories will never be
told they'll they'll die with me but you
know he he destroyed lots of people's
lives and in a very horrific way so yeah
I mean I I'm a keeper of a lot of
Secrets
the the thing that strikes me is so I've
got a young daughter and the thing you
just told me about Madeleine McCann is
something else kind of stay with me for
a little while it's awful
I couldn't do what you do I couldn't be
immersed in that world Non-Stop and just
sort of see that darkness and and and
doubly I couldn't do it where the cases
might not be solved if there was a
constant sense of closure that's
something for things that like you said
right at the beginning of the
conversation they're just running on and
on and potentially there will never be
closure does it affect you yeah yeah I
mean I I'd be
if you ask me that question 10 years ago
I'd probably say no I'd probably say no
no you know I I get on with it no you
know over the last
three years I I have struggled with my
mental health you know there's no doubt
that these things have impacted on me
you can't you can't see what I see and
and not be affected by it you can't take
on the responsibility of helping people
who I come into people's lives at the
most traumatic time of their life and by
and large particularly the work I do now
I'm their last hope everything else
they've tried they've tried the police
they've tried every other aspect and
they've been let down they've been
failed and I come along
and
and I and they see it as a glimmer of
hope and I always try to keep that
realistic balance there because I say to
them look you know I I can't I can't
tell you I'll solve this I can't tell
you I will catch the offender I will
tell you if I take this case on that
I'll I'll get you new information you
know there isn't a single case that I've
worked on
and I can say this confident you know I
thought probably I thought about this
yeah probably about two three years ago
just before I my release my book hunting
killers and I thought to myself do you
know do I always make a difference and
I've looked at every case and I can tell
you categorically every case I've worked
on I have found a new information I I
went out to Kuala Lumpur to investigate
the death of a young girl who ended up
falling Nine Stories and uh dead on the
floor and I went over there and I did an
investigation and as a direct result of
my investigation it was opened up as a
homicide I was convinced that her death
wasn't suicide which is what they put it
down to and it was opened up as a
homicide so every time I find new
information uh and I suppose that's my
Mantra really so I I'm always confident
that when I take a case on and I keep
chipping away at it and working at it in
some of these cases it's healthy to put
them down for a couple of months
six months seven months and pick them up
again and you sometimes see things
differently plus also you know I I take
on cases that I don't get paid for so I
have to balance that around the work
that I do get paid for
um and it does affect you it affects you
because I'm still a human being you know
there are
there's there's a couple of tracks music
tracks which accompany a couple of
really horrific child abuse videos that
still sit in my head
and I you know and those tracks you know
and I hear them at certain times of the
year because when there's a Christmas
track you know always kind of stops me
in my track when I hear it and there are
the times when things come back to me
you know I I've I've seen the most
horrific injuries to people
and and certain times something will
happen and you'll see something and it
will just bring back a memory
um so yeah you know and I and I've
worked really hard at that you know I've
I've spoken to you know I've had some
therapy around that uh to be able to
deal with that and I think it it I live
in a dark world I live in a pretty dark
world and and I have to make sure that I
don't that I come out of that you know
so I I work really hard I train Fitness
you know I'm gym regularly I look after
myself I eat well
um you know I've got a good family
support around me and
um
you know and I and I think it's really
hard you know I've got a great partner
who's very supportive and I think that
that whole process is really important
because if you don't have that support
around you then you you just live in a
dark World all the time
well look Mark it's been just as
fascinating to have you back a second
time as the first time and um I mean I'm
just really grateful there are people
like you out there who are dedicating
your time to finding Justice
for these people who've been treated
terribly so great to meet you again and
thanks so much for your time great to
talk thank you yeah I've been very very
quickly like I didn't expect it to
happen that quick we literally had the
evidence he was meant to turn up with
his
um
with his campervan and second 13 year
old girl to a campsite
where he intended on what we started
doing this
what he said he was going to do